okay Rosa yeah Rosa tell me where you're
from where'd you grow up I grew up in
Los Angeles California and South Central
and tell me about your family you grew
up with both your parents in the
beginning my mom wasn't there she were
under find out later she was addicted to
some type of drug that kept her away so
mom was doing drugs and where is dad in
the beginning I'm like my first few
years like 67 and dad wasn't there the I
was doing the same thing so both parents
were doing drugs and they were out of
the picture it's so I found out yet yeah
my I jumped different places I've been
foster homes different family members
house is been almost everybody until my
dad got a so back together any came and
got us
it's five of us yeah at what age was
that when he I was like a six or seven
so six or seven he came back in the
picture
yes but between before that I was moved
different places Wow and how was your
life after that came back yeah in the
beginning it was okay it was good yeah
two things changed up mom wasn't there
so in substitute for mom dad will have
somebody else or other things things
changed up I guess a once there's didn't
work anymore once they got broken things
changed up that attitude even changed or
was different so it the mood and the
house was more down or unhappy yeah your
brothers and sisters yes yeah I have
three brothers and one sister I'm number
four so how was your childhood generally
how would you describe it Oh their views
yeah what kind
I've been worked when I was jumping from
different places I got disciplined some
for their own personal reasons because I
didn't do something the way they wanted
it to be the I could have forgot a piece
of paper or on the ground when I was
supposed to make sure the whole floor
was clean the stuff like that I've been
I don't know if you same unless I've
been touched by family it wasn't
believed they didn't believe me when it
came out
and I heard it that bothered me
especially because I knew it was true
that type of abuse which caused me later
on in school too
I want to say be abusive because I
wasn't just beating on people but I was
the fighting type I fought what age were
you when you left home I was what for
like 15 I'd say 15 I left I went through
jail and all that f-15i right away and
was gone
where'd you go I didn't travel around
the world but I travel around and said
orders ever like familiar places I
bounced around myself and went places I
could met new people I
just about what you do for money I took
it at that time I've done things I
didn't want to do at that time and then
I had changed I took it I do what was
needed to be done yet especially after
time I was about myself I was with my
baby daddy
sir I was cold pinched I felt like I had
to do things but after I lost my babies
and I moved away after I left my
placement went to jail went to a
placement and got my own plate living
out of my own I changed god changed it
gave me a different way of thinking I
see life differently especially when my
son came my son changed my life I was 19
I had him and he changed everything
because I felt like I had to what I do
he go and see so I had to be example
especially because his dad or wasn't it
wasn't know for sure thing and we knew
that in beginning it wasn't a for-sure
thing so I went along with knowing that
I may or may not had this person by my
side no I know who his father is but I'm
saying I still made the decision and
keep my baby or light yeah
live life if it was just me and my son
awesome did you raise yourself yes until
I messed up and he got chicken from what
age was he he was nine months when he
first got chicken and it took a while
but I got him back and after I got him
back a year later I had a sister I kept
her
she was lost her it was her first
birthday yeah all her birthday and I
haven't been back to me since so you
lost both kids at her first birthday
yeah yeah I did
they've been away from you ever since
then I've been back for seeing them or
stuff like that but I haven't fully
gotten back in my custody yet and
luckily our gladdened by the grace of
God they were family right now at first
there was an assistant but it's got to
the point where today with family and
they can stay with family and till I get
my stuff together
what is your drug today today
surprisingly so is crack cocaine that's
crazy because I used to hate crack
because I end up finding out I said
where mom and dad did and that's what
that was the reason for mom and dad
being away I hated the people who
couldn't smoke around me or anything
even when I moved first move down here
they had the way to our I thought the
room in order to light that someone's
respect they have fun but I hate the
smell acting just from knowing what it
does or I held feeling a bad feeling
towards me because I knew that's where
my it kept that's what kept mom and dad
away and then in the midst of living
down here I started smoking a crystal
again that changed everything
it's I was going to school at first I
stopped going to school I even didn't
even I stopped leaving my room my baby
daddy was there with me at first but
when he left and it was just me
everything changed
for a while I didn't leave in my room I
made it people bring it to me everything
I needed littered and then I started
coming out my room just in my building
and one go outside when I started crack
I had to get content or okay enough with
going outside because I what they call
it third party I didn't want nobody else
going to get my stuff from me because of
how people are especially if they do the
same drug it don't come back the same
way so I had to figure out a way to do
it on my own and for the last two and a
half years yeah I've been doing been
doing me I hate it I really do
I don't know if I can cut in line but
this drug isn't [ __ ] this truck
has changed my life I miss my babies
let's hanno so strong because it's like
I'm stuck I've been stuck down here for
a long time I don't even go there for
this is the even being right here on
this street is far from where I am
I became anti-social I don't even like
to even bring them up in a conversation
because it's two months but it kills me
because I smile I say I smoked to stay
out of my head because when I get to
thinking my thoughts are bad because I'm
emotionally a missing [ __ ] that right
now based on relationships I've been in
I let men give me like this but before I
can catch you or grabby it was it was
too late my emotions I found out became
over one I never knew that your emotions
can be this strong
that's why I love God or I'm glad to
know there is a guy because he the only
one I know or can't help me with me and
I hate that I know that and I'm still
not doing what I need to do to be where
I should but I still have faith though
and I even in the mist everything I
speak on him I try to speak it to
existence so I know in due time this
that I'm going through will flip i
cutted me in a flip I go back to the
good like the other life outside this is
me going to church me following God's
footsteps that's what I want that's what
I mean that I once was there I need that
I miss it but it's crazy dad
this really got me stuck it's hard to
just and I never knew that and I hate
that I had to get into this to find that
out
but I pray and I believe that by the
grace of God before my heart starts
beating I will be able to live my life I
will be able to flip I want to see me
light and cuz I know once I stop this
I'm gonna be able to call myself a woman
I don't see myself as that right now
because I know things that should be
being done it's not but I I want to see
that because I'm gonna be bad and beauty
I want to see I want to feel it I want
some pot of hot
I want some pot of time had peace on
earth I can say I was happy unless it
made me cry all of that and I guess I'm
going through this to find out what was
it that I didn't have strong enough to
keep me like that or keep me in that
because I thought I was but obviously
you see I'm not I never seen this coming
I never expected this on anything
especially crack okay I had to take a
head before I got over here I was trying
to take a hit before I came in here at
like this drug is deep even though I
feel weak yeah I know God is strong so I
know in due time before my heart stops
and he calls me home I will start this
and be able to live sober and faithful
life especially because I have somebody
in my life that's women milk I love him
but this drug right here I see yes I
wish I knew him I had him before this he
I hate I wanna he's the one I want to
marry I said she want to spend my life
with you
I'm wondering I want his last name like
I said she did in this Deen we've been
together for years
and a lot of it is me I'm [ __ ] up and
for some reason he still loved me he
still did especially for the things he
don't know I just wish especially
because of this relationship and my kids
my babies I just I just wish it will
come to an end sooner than later and I
Sisley hate that it's here it's
something I got it is something that is
missing I got to figure it out and I
hope I do sooner than later they say on
gives singing time to get sick in time
but I am tired though
and I just keep saying that until it
happened I'm gonna keep saying it's what
I have only God knows how I really feel
I missed God I miss my babies I miss it
I miss the live this [ __ ] is killing me
all these wake these people is waking
these people is awaking and for me to be
around them it's like I'm being it's
like I'm ok with it or it's like I'm
even becoming I got me no I don't want
to die like this I do not want this to
be the real what they tell my babies how
mommy left I don't want this to be it I
need it to be something different I need
I need something to know something
different and honestly I try not to eat
I hate to even say that because it's
like how can say how can I say I love
them if I'm doing what I'm doing
[ __ ] with me but I hate I loved him I
really do I love him I hate that I can't
even be there so it's like damn this
drug is strong life is life is real life
is serious you rarely gotta be careful
on what you doing how you doing it cuz
you can just it's something cuz so easy
like wow but I have I got faithful I'll
be with my babies again that I will be a
wife and had you know how I'd be able to
have it you know the fairy second stream
that is not impossible to have I want it
and I know I can't be God said I can't
anything is possible through Christ
Jesus and my one wish my number one wish
on my prayer is God please I wanna have
that before I die whatever it said keep
me strong please let me live through
this to be able to have that before I go
thank you so much
yeah do you want good luck getting thank
your life together thank
this is deep
you